[Music]
in the Southeast of England in a country
garden bursting with life Charles Darwin
paces it's the summer of 1859 and the
great gentlemen scientist is surrounded
by living things in all their glorious
forms wildflowers crowd the path bees
gently hung across multi-coloured blooms
overhead a mighty oak tree casts a
dappled shade squirrels darting up and
down the trunk
mushrooms spring up in the cool damp
shade at their base and even deeper in
the leaf litter earth worms and maggots
wriggle
in the distance the lowing of cows and
the cooing of wood pigeons adds to the
symphony
Darwyn revels in the life that surrounds
him and Ponder's it just as he pondered
the exotic animals he recorded and
collected in his voyages to the tropics
some 20 years earlier
it was during those years in the early
1830s spent aboard the illustrious HMS
Beagle on its five-year mission to map
the coasts of South America that the
young Darwin a 20-something year old
naturalist devoted every waking hour to
scientific analysis of fossils and all
manner of diverse life he came into
contact with from giant land turtles to
reptilians colossal whales and even a
vast array of seemingly insignificant
insects many of which had never been
studied before some life-forms in the
Galapagos Islands in particular a
previously largely unexplored hotbed for
biodiversity varied ever-so-slightly
from one another from island to island
hinting at a common ancestor at some
time in the past
[Music]
now 20 years after the publishing of his
modestly successful account of his
travels and on the verge of releasing a
newer altogether more revolutionary work
one that would eclipse the first in both
controversy and ultimately success all
this life in all its variety of forms he
imagines belongs to a great tree
[Music]
like the oak that stretches out above
him grasping toward the afternoon Sun
living species are like the green buds
and leaves of the tip of every branch
the branches themselves were once green
shoots to ancestor species of what came
before dead now but a clear path to
those we see today
[Music]
tracing the branches back they merge two
more primitive ancestors the foundation
of many species yet to come
ultimately all the branches come back to
the trunk the ancestral line born of the
first sapling the first seedling the
first ACORN
[Music]
Darwyn sees all life exists and has ever
existed positioned on this vast Tree of
Life each new species to arrive has its
own unique innovations allowing it to
branch out on its own
some will flourish maybe even sprouting
successes of their own others will
wither and die but all are built on the
template of the branch that came before
and at the beginning
long before the trunk even began to grow
a single acorn the very first ancestor
the very first template on which all
living things are built
but where and when did that first
ancestor live and what form did it take
Darwin imagines an early Earth rocky
devoid of life but on its surface a warm
little pond has just the right chemistry
the building blocks of existence
it's here he suspects in these murky
pools that we could find our first
ancestor
humble beginnings for the breathtaking
diversity that is to come a primordial
soup billions of years ago
but that was nearly 160 years ago and
much has been learned since Darwin's day
[Music]
since Darwin scientists have been
reconstructing trees of life in ever
more detail using the characteristics of
living and extinct creatures to map the
pattern of branches and discover common
ancestors right back to the first
the last Universal common ancestor or
Luca for short is the ultimate
grandfather to everything that came
later to all of life on earth we now
know that life falls into one of three
domains all animals plants and fungi are
eukaryotes with complex structures
inside their cells even some
single-celled microscopic creatures are
eukaryotes too like amoebas and algae
making do with just one complex cell
everything else alive is single-celled
but that's not to say that they are less
diverse these single cells inhabit every
conceivable surface as long as there is
water they are adapted to thrive in
conditions that no other life could
withstand there are single cells that
can survive intense heat cold saltiness
and acidity and the denizens of this
hidden world can be classified as either
bacteria or archaea depending on their
chemistry
because eukaryotes are so much more
complex than either bacteria or archaea
scientists place them higher up on a
tree of life
they came later while the two other
domains are more primitive so Luca was a
single cell that much is clear it makes
sense to for the earliest ancestor to be
among the simplest life possible but
modern science goes further than that by
analyzing the DNA of bacteria and
archaea we can build trees of life for
these primitive domains too instead of
looking for shared physical
characteristics researchers look for
genes that are in common in 2016
scientists published a list of 355 genes
that were probably part of Lucas DNA
which opens a window on how this first
ancestor functioned and the kinds of
conditions it could withstand but the
view through that window is surprising
lucas genes give it the capacity to
metabolize hydrogen as a source of
energy
they also given the tools for surviving
at extremely high temperatures this
felucca is something unexpected adapted
not to Darwin's warm little pond but to
a much more hostile environment
able to survive in scorching acidic
waters
[Applause]
in February in 1977 a century and a half
after the Beagle made its fateful
circumnavigation around the earth a new
generation of scientists in a research
vessel of the South American coast made
a remarkable discovery
[Music]
as part of their studies into volcanic
activity around Darwin's beloved
Galapagos Islands they dropped cameras
down to a depth of more than two and a
half kilometers when the photos came
back they revealed something entirely
unexpected
[Music]
instead of lava hot water poured out of
the Galapagos rift towering underwater
chimneys emitting plumes of it darkened
by minerals and metals so it looked like
smoke billowing from the seafloor these
scientists were the first to discover
Earth's hydrothermal vents
affectionately nicknamed black smokers
bizarre structures that form a seawater
penetrates cracks in the crust
magma close to the surfaces super heats
the water to almost 400 degrees Celsius
flash boiling it and spewing it back
into the deep ocean like an underwater
geyser on its way the hot water pulls
minerals from the surrounding magma and
rock enriching it into iron sulfur
hydrogen ammonia
the minerals in the superheated water
build up around the vent creating alien
chimneys in the ocean depths
but there was more two and a half
kilometers down no sunlight can
penetrate the darkness is intense and
the pressure is 250 times that at sea
level and yet around these mysterious
black smokers life was found
not a few cowering crushed sea creatures
but vast and blossoming ecosystems clams
the size of dinner plates bristling
clusters of tubeworms and alien hairy
Yeti crabs all thriving in this curious
hostile microcosm this entire vent
ecosystem relies on another unseen
component single-celled bacteria and
archaea which have the unique ability to
convert the chemical energy from the
black smokers complement of minerals
into biologically available energy food
elsewhere on earth all food chains
ultimately come back to the Sun plants
capture the sun's light energy and
converted into sugars which then support
complex food chains of herbivores and
carnivores but on the ocean floor there
is no Sun no light to provide that
energy the single-celled organisms that
live here take hydrogen gas or iron
sulfide and similar chemicals and use
them to power their own metabolisms the
other animals eat them for energy or
enslave them within their bodies to
produce energy in return for safe harbor
in this way an entire community is built
based on the abilities of these weird
single-celled organisms completely
unreliable
and it's these conditions that would
have been ideal for Luca our last common
ancestor with all other life the genes
that Luca possessed would have allowed
it to survive 400 degree waters it would
have given it all the means to extract
energy from hydrogen it would have given
Luca the survival skills for this
unimaginably weird habitat at some point
in the deep and distant past
it's now thought at our earliest
single-celled ancestors clung to vents
like these our lineage may not have seen
the Sun for millions of years
[Music]
but that's not quite the whole story
although Luca may have been equipped
with the tools to survive and thrive on
a hydrothermal vent other clues point to
an altogether different kind of
beginning for life on earth scientists
who study the chemical reactions
involved in life's metabolism believe
that the ultraviolet light provided by
the Sun was necessary to get some of
those reactions started deep beneath the
ocean there's no substitute for that
kind of energy so the earliest
life-forms must have proliferated when
the Sun still shone
once more advanced metabolisms were up
and running life could do without the UV
boost but those earliest reactions were
reliant on it
and since chemistry works better when
things are concentrated in small volumes
of liquid perhaps Darwin's warm little
pond wasn't so far from the true cradle
of life after all but how can these two
lines of evidence be reconciled one
points to hellish heat crushing pressure
and a servic chemistry the other to
sun-baked slime in a much more familiar
setting the key may lie in the Lukas
true identity our last Universal common
ancestor isn't necessarily the first
life form that appeared on the earth it
is merely the first one whose
descendants survived over billions of
years to diversify into all living
things we see today so life could indeed
have started out in a warm pond relying
on the particular sun-soaked chemistry
found there perhaps in those early years
it had the chance to become
well-established and so proliferated
spreading to other warm ponds and larger
seas all over the Earth's surface
[Music]
everything was going well for global
colonization until the catastrophe
changed the course of our world forever
for hundreds of millions of years fire
rained from the skies thanks to the
cosmic dance of giant planets far beyond
Earth asteroids were sent hurtling
towards this fragile cradle of life this
bombardment would have vaporized surface
water and injected heat and exotic
chemicals into the ocean wreaking havoc
on the tentative first life only the
hardiest variants that could survive
this Cataclysm remained driven towards
the places in the ocean that avoided the
worst of the bombardment the depths of
the deepest oceans
despite darkness and oppressive
pressures became a refuge from the fire
and fury on the surface here at least
the water remained the chemistry stayed
the same and hydrothermal vents became
beacons for the single-celled survivors
they provided warmth and chemical energy
that these struggling organisms needed
to stay alive adapting to use hydrogen
as a fuel instead of sunlight was the
only way to ensure the future of their
lineage
meanwhile the surface was sterilized the
first life that it gained foothold in
warm little ponds on the surface was
wiped out instantly destined to leave no
descendants its succession stamped out
[Music]
this was potentially the first great
extinction leaving behind just one weird
group of survivors cowering in the
depths how do we know that this
extinction really happened with so few
rocks and no fossils from this early
time it's certainly hard to be sure
about the sagas that gripped lucca and
its relations four billion years ago but
this is a tale that explains the clues
that all living things carry in their
cells to this day and there's one final
piece of the puzzle that seems to
corroborate our story
the asteroid bombardment eventually
tailed off as the solar system settled
down and remaining asteroids were swept
up by the planets of the inner solar
system the sterile earth finally cooled
again by about 3.8 billion years ago but
something miraculous followed just a
hundred million years later the rocks
bear a record of life the first fossils
physical structures and chemical
signatures are locked into rocks that
are 3.7 billion years old these are
sophisticated single cells living and
dying at the Earth's surface in little
more than a geological blink of the eye
after a sterilizing Cataclysm scientists
believe that life like this would have
taken many hundreds of millions of years
to come about so this simply wasn't
enough time for it to start afresh after
the end of the bombardment instead it
must have survived the Earth's
devastation somehow hiding away
developing and evolving as soon as
things calmed down
they were primed ready to burst forth
and take over the world
so hydrothermal vents were most likely
the unexpected but his sensual refuge
for our earliest ancestors during the
first apocalypse
they were the warm little ponds of that
terrible time they were sanctuary for
Luka a record of that time preserved
deep in our collective genetic memory
[Music]
Darwin was probably right in more ways
than he could ever have expected
[Music]
next time we'll discover the devastating
but life-giving convulsions of the first
plate tectonics and explore an
alternative altogether more alien
explanation for the origins of life on
Earth you've been watching the entire
history of the earth don't forget to
Like and subscribe and let us know what
you think in the comments and we'll see
you next week
[Music]